third covid 19 vaccine about to get
approval for emergency use
cbs news has learned the centers for
disease control and prevention has
alerted states the food and drug
administration's approval
for the one-shot johnson and johnson
vaccine is expected
later today that means nearly 4 million
shots could be shipped out as soon as
tomorrow
the new shipment comes with fresh
warnings from top health officials who
say the new variants of the coronavirus
are why many states should not start
relaxing restrictions
so far more than 22.6 million americans
are now fully vaccinated
there were more than 73 000 new
coronavirus cases in the u.s on friday
that
is down 76 percent from the all-time
one-day high setback on january 2nd but
there are concerns that progress against
the virus could
level off michael george is here with
more on this story michael good morning
jeff good morning the emergency use
authorization for johnson and johnson's
vaccine is expected today according to
the white house
while the efficacy is lower than other
vaccines it's a single dose instead of
two shots
and it can be stored in regular
refrigerators doctors say it's just one
more tool
to stop the spread of kovic
the u.s is already vaccinating 1.4
million people a day
thank you so much my golden ticket
pre-school teacher lindsey jackson
i feel like i am finally able to take a
deep breath
this isn't just a step for me to protect
me but also the sweet little kiddos that
are in my class
the food and drug administration meeting
online late friday
paved the way for a wider distribution
of johnson johnson's vaccine
but johnson johnson is expected to start
small
with three to four million doses
available less than the 10 million they
hope to provide by the end of the month
but the biden administration says it
will step up to help expand the number
of doses
we're going to use every conceivable way
to expand manufacturing
of the vaccine the third vaccine to make
even more rapid progress in getting
shots in people's arms
this is our path out dr rochelle
wolenski heads the centers for disease
control
we are at the precipice of having
another vaccine in our tool boxes
the johnson and johnson kova 19 vaccine
like many of you i'm excited about news
that another
safe and effective vaccine option could
be coming
as quickly as next week the third
vaccine comes after
several weeks of seeing cases drop but
now their signs progress
has stalled the average number of new
cases is
increasing again and masculist party
goers this one organized in utah by a 17
year old
could wreck the party we may be done
with the virus but clearly the virus
is not done with us we cannot get
comfortable
or give in to a false sense of security
that the worst of the pandemic is behind
us not
now not when mass vaccination is so
very close and that's exactly why health
officials say it's just too early for
states to roll back restrictions
new coveted variants are on the rise so
masks and social distancing
still just as critical dana all right
michael thank you